how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything marvel cinematic universe
today we're going to be talking about
black panther 2
and it really is hard to believe that
it's already been about a month and a
half
since chadwick boseman our black panther
and an amazing person has passed away
now since then people have come out with
all sorts of videos and
theories about what exactly is going to
happen now that chadwick
is gone what exactly is going to happen
in black panther 2
and although there are some pretty good
theories and ideas out there
it doesn't seem like we're going to be
seeing any of them happen on screen
anytime soon now the last update that we
got from marvel studios about a month
and a half ago about where their heads
are at right now
in regards to black panther 2 they told
us that they weren't really thinking
about it
black panther 2 wasn't really a concern
of theirs what their concern was
focusing on chadwick boseman's family
and mourning the loss of a loved one
there are countless videos out there
showing what an amazing person chadwick
boseman was
so of course this is going to take a
very long time to get over
but today we do have a small update from
letitia wright who of course plays shuri
t'challa's sister and black panther and
of course the mcu
leticia wright was recently interviewed
on net a porter
in which she gave her thoughts on
chadwick boseman's passing and where
they are
at right now in the interview while
talking about her role as shuri and
black panther and how iconic it was
the topic of reprising her role as shuri
for the next black panther film was
brought up
the article says bozeman was family to
write
she refers to him as my brother and a
month on from his death any discussion
of reprising her most
famous role remains impossible who's the
favorite sibling
i mean families don't really play
favorites it's me
i was gonna say me but i was trying to
be nice atesha would go on to say in the
interview
we're just still mourning chad so it's
not something i even want to think about
the thought of doing it without him is
kind of strange we're just grieving at
the moment
so it's trying to find the light in the
midst of it all
so as of right now she says it's not
something that she's even thinking about
and she also says
we're still mourning chad this means
that marvel studios or ryan coogler or
anybody has
not yet brought up the topic of black
panther 2.
and again rightfully so it hasn't even
been two months yet since chadwick has
passed away
so right now there have been no talks
about black panther 2 or what they're
going to do
moving forward at least with letitia
wright but i'm sure of course ryan
coogler and some others have been
thinking about what they're going to do
moving forward
could latisha wright's character shuri
black panther's sister go on
and become black panther after all she
technically would be the next heir even
though she would have to compete for it
which also brings up the fact that maybe
umbaku could go on to become the next
black panther
or is there some possible way to bring
back killmonger
change his story just a little bit and
have him become the next black panther
or
could the studio possibly be thinking to
recast the character
i want to know what you all think what
the fans think is the best move for
marvel studios moving forward with black
panther 2. do you think they should
recast do you think it should be shuri
do you think it should be killmonger who
do you think it should be
what do you think it should be moving
forward be sure to let me know in the
comments down below because pretty soon
i will be making a black panther 2 video
about what the fans think should happen
in the sequel
so let me know don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you stay up to
date with all the latest in the mcu and
so you can enter this week's giveaway
giving away
another iron spider funko pop because
everybody loved it so much
don't forget to follow me on instagram
and twitter for live updates and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
you